I welcome to this video
round 9 of the London tournament here
for the candidates - yeah to get to to
know the next Challenger for watch
ambient Vishy Anand later this year it's
been a very exciting tournament and
today was a quite quite an eventful
round and maybe the most entertaining
and an interesting round up to now it's
been very enjoyable today being here in
London - to watch it live with the nice
commentary provided by by the
grandmasters or on-site
it was very nice today to visit I was
also joined by my friend and also
channel colleague trifon also known as
King's crusher you probably know his
channel as well it was very nice to be
with him at the at the event and and
followed the games and they were all
interesting now in a way with different
sort of focus for all games some were
more tactical some very interesting from
more strategical point of view okay
let's go through the games and I start
with kramnik against cards which
obviously a.m. before the round seemed
like the most attractive game and it was
interesting and it wasn't an uneventful
draw so kramnik is one point behind so
with a win he would actually catch
Townsend and be right in the middle of
it so what do we get
Catalan yeah black has the number of
enterprising options here mostly it can
go c5 - to make the game a bit more
unbalanced but Carlson certainly is more
informed for a solid game so he plays d5
and Bishop e7 we get
the same thing that he had yesterday
with white actually against them Aronian
and it was a rather uneventful draw
Kramnik however has prepared prepared to
surprise him he went 95 which is um yeah
which is an interesting move it's in a
way more ambitious than Quincy - because
you want to recapture on c4 with a
knight and simply build up a good
position with the great bishop on g2 and
a possible line for example is here
let's say black plays c5 just normal
moves you can easily get a position like
this on the board where this Bishop is
simply so much better than the c8 bishop
that wide already has got a really clear
advantage if you actually look at this
with the computer it won't give big
advantage for white because the computer
doesn't understand the long-term
problems of this bishop the 95 move here
really requires some very direct counter
play and contemplation Knight to c6
which is for a long time considered to
be the the best reply at first it looks
a bit strange but it makes sure that
White's pieces white has got two active
pieces and both are now attacked in a
way this night must take on c6 and
immediately or after the exchange a went
Bishop c6 but white also could play this
and for example after white captures
rook b8 black has got a very active
position or not on d3 but the queen is
putting some pressure on d4 let's say
Knight c3 there should be 7
this kind of position where black is
coming with c5 he doesn't have any big
big issues here it should be M about
about equal now maybe like it's even
more comfortable I'd it's it's not not a
problem why it's idea however something
different he wants to take with the
bishop and this is what prominent played
takes Knight takes Queen II 897 with
Czech Queen takes and this is a very
well known theoretical position and
which is implied really a big number of
times what is the idea very often we get
a position where white actually enjoys
an extra pawn like this let's say Queen
e4 e5 takes Queen takes Queen seafoam
and white has got an extra pawn but
blacks got big activity is got those
ideas Bishop to h3 this is the problem
White's King and King side is very weak
and like has got exactly the right
Bishop to take care of those those weak
squares so black is very very okay yeah
but it's not easy to play this position
because your porn down you always need
to somehow prove your compensation and
this is in a way what chrome league
wanted to have he didn't play exactly
this he played them something else
interesting Queen c2 which it's very
uncommon in this position um where the
test cards points black now play d5 and
now rook to d1 and this is really an
unknown way to play white is not really
taking this pawn he just wants to catch
up in development and at the end have to
better structure and this is actually
working out nicely in this game so the
rook b8 activating the rook Knight c3 h6
looks like a bit of a time loss but
Bishop to g5 was
was an annoying move threatening 95 for
example yeah age six after that Kramnik
took and developed with the temple a
route deform so now I have a look at
this position isn't why just distinctly
better
yeah probably he is it looks like like
must play with extreme care to not run
into some very unpleasant especially
very unpleasant end game if you are
look at this position with let's say
Queens exchanged then white will have a
big edge here can relatively easily
museum and an easy way defend the Queen
side and to always have pressure against
those big pawns I'm not so sure what
like should have done differently
because it looks like white is really a
substantially better him the computer
wants to play some moves like g5 for
example and I don't really believe it
yeah counter plate just the normal moves
Bishop e6 covering c4 look t1 and now he
doubled on the B file which makes sense
some pressure on between Queen d2 yeah
this is an interesting move intending
rook to d8 this is what Carter played
King to f7 there was also sometimes the
idea to take on h6 o king here 7s
reflecting move and now I played f3 just
controlling important squares and maybe
I'm intending to play E for later
controlling even more info on squares so
very nice positional game Mac ramnik
he's got a good position rook e8 and
this is interesting very interesting
here I've at least expected something
entirely different
he played now queen III which is a
really interesting way to go about it he
also could have played Queen c2 which
was what I am expected to Queen King
back and then maybe a move like Bishop
c1 to have b2 protected then maybe try
afore and somehow make progress it's not
so bad to drop the Bishop back because
there's essentially one Bishop against
two rooks so like he needs to use two
rooks to on yeah two to tie one Bishop
up and this is fine for white I think
also probably played much more in a much
more direct way and very good where he
actually queen e3 rook takes and looks
before this was the idea using this pin
and there are still two very weak pawns
yeah Magnus dropped dropped this rook
bag covering c7 and now I played bouquet
form and the only thing that I know is
it looks really like a great position
for white he's got those weaknesses to
attack and a7 is especially bad at the
moment
in fact Carlsen simply ignored this pawn
and and sacrificed it if plywood go rook
eight playing some passive looking move
there's even ideas of sometimes
sacrificing on h6 just the sample line
if you take here black is in big trouble
let's say age five to go Queen g5 and
this rook h5 threatened and this is
actually over no way to save safe black
so this was a threat you cannot go rook
an eight because of this Bishop h6 and
he played a really cool movement rook e8
which nobody really understood at at the
time when it was played but he had seen
a really great technical resource and
let's have a look at this okay seven
rook takes Queen takes so Cromley grab
grab the pawn and Queen before this was
one of cards in some ideas attacking the
the Queen not attacking the Queen
activating the Queen
it attacks c3 so what is why it's
supposed to do Kramnik calculated mostly
as he said in the press conference queen
d4 at the move that he played after this
there c5 this kind of continuation but
it he actually said in the press
conference that he belief that black has
got decent drawing chances in this
position it still doesn't seem like very
comfortable but black has got some
activity he's not passively defending
weaknesses now he played Bishop to e5
and here Carson came up with with a
great move and it's it's not so
difficult to see the move I mean
actually saw it in the commentary room
and suggested it but the great thing is
not this move the great thing is that he
calculated all this free moves before
when he went rook e8 because this is
only working the move that is coming now
ninety-five it's only working because of
the rook it's got this x-ray power on
the e-file and after 95 I think it's
maybe over with any winning
tens for white the big point is if white
would go here and grab the the piece
there's Queenie one check and Queenie 2
and E five is just saying so you would
get it back
like Queen f2 rookie five and it's the
draw white can also not play for win
King edge three King f1 and something
like this actually leads to checkmate
can't continue this if you like say here
and it's made just one line there's
there a couple of other mates so this is
not working so white needs to do
something else in this position and he
he played Queen c7 which caused an ant a
twist Quincy Foyet all all this
calculated beforehand attacking a - Andy
- Jim kramnik played a three if he ever
of taken here and it's a simple double
attack and the problem is also let's say
this e to pawn is falling then there's
immediately f3 week and I mean it's
opposite kind of bishops so around here
it's probably probably just the draw
kramnik played a three and now Magnus
played f6 in fact here there's a funny
move Bishop c6 which was suggested in
the commentary room by dr. John nun one
of the first English grandmasters a
British grandmasters um it was a really
strong player like I know top 20 top 30
in the 1980s and early 90s he's now
retired from from professional chess I
mean playing professional chances
involved with chess and
editor and book author and all kinds of
fields is tied to chest but it's not
playing in tournaments anymore he came
up with this move and it's really
interesting it's actually a way for
black to trying to win which seems weird
his to falls down but black actually has
has ideas there's some pressure on this
Bishop does pressure honey - it all
seems to go like this king - f1 twin b5
and taking me five and then there are
crazy lines like f4 f6 and Ruby g6
counter-attacking on c6 it all ends up
with the draw anyway but Carlton wasn't
in for any advented adventures draw was
fine so I played f6 twins were exchanged
and now black got the pawn back on e to
his Scott activity he's got the rook on
the second rank and those pawns are both
weak they continued a couple of more
moves but it's around here it's really
just a draw oops yeah and here it was it
was agreed Ron king of one look here and
then there's rook d7 with this counter
play and everything will get exchanged
now like him oops
f8 King g8 takes takes and okay it's
dead there's simply nothing going on so
a draw very important for Carlsen I mean
to not have lost the game and let
Kramnik catch up with him so on good
result for Magnus let's have a look at
the other games need to check here
need to pull up the game just a second
yeah here we go the next game I'm going
to look at is some girl front against
Aronian so Aronian still the co-leader
with three wins and no loss and girl
Phan is playing white he won yesterday
against the Java so suddenly he was in a
good mood to put up a good fight so we
got this classical Queens gambit iam
with Knight bg7 against Bishop f4 a land
that I've played myself on numerous
times with black with white actually
also but with black mostly yeah Bishop
b2 was dolphin smooth him the move that
has yeah gotten much more popular
recently to be honest I never understood
it I must be honest here and I never
really got the point of this move if
black wants to just have a solid
position then he can easily just take on
c4 which has been played number of times
right often castles and then you get
something like this a six a four c5
takes Knight b6 something like that and
mostly it's an isolated pawn position
where this Bishop is not in a good good
spot I don't know this is one of the
types of lines that you can get it's
really very solid for black then when
Aronian played c6 that was clear to me
that he was trying to win this game at
least trying to get some sort of
imbalance ok castles and Knight h5 this
is one idea to imbalance the game trying
to get the bishop am it worked out
because this bishop simply has no square
i played we should be 5 which is a good
idea black cannot really take here
because after d takes in 5 this night is
really stranded on h5 the
Media thread is g4 and black needs to
play some they're uncomfortable moves
like g6 to not get in much more trouble
so it went differently played f6 was the
idea
Bishop dropped back and he played oops
f5 in fact I've thought it would be
interesting here to immediately take and
then play a5 could be a good option
Bishop to d6 and maybe even playing g5 g
for this is a very crude but it can be
really effective I know it seems like a
good alternative he played he 5f5
immediately and now White has got this
chance and he took it to play Bishop b5
yeah aronia now he still doesn't want to
take on e5 because of the deep own
recapture which leaves the night
stranded so he played 9 f6 first geffen
played 83 this is really a threat h3 it
has a threat this means Bishop h2 with
the threat securing the bishop on on a
great diagonal so like to took it and we
have this additional exchange here and
now it's yeah it's a typical stone world
structure but one that is really quite
comfortable for black the stone wall is
not a bad opening it's just very
demanding from black blacks point of
view because of those those weaknesses
that it entails with e5 but here he
managed to put up this structure with a
pawn on e5 which is in comparison much
more comfortable because a piece only 5
is simply is simply menacing but pawn is
not so dangerous blacks got a fine
position now Bishop g5 Queen here to
protect you 3 and a couple of
very normal looking moves that actually
just improve the position for both sides
there should be three group to c7 this
is flexible you can switch over to the
kingside it can we use in the center
also 92 should be h5 there may be black
and tends to exchange the still not good
bishop on h5 9f form and here we get a
forcing continuation of course like
doesn't want to drop it back to have 7
this this bishop covering the pond he
just took it and girl found you captured
with the pawn it seems ok he didn't want
to go here I guess maybe because black
will get g5 in at some point maybe even
immediately he takes a fall said the the
more more solid choice that stabilizes
against the g5 idea the weak the
weakness of this move is that defies
weak now look at this pressure on the
pawn here in fact the Gaffin also could
have played c5 this would be answered
with g5 and it's not clear it's not
clear it's like this is the the
consequence with good play for black
probably he didn't want one then played
Queen e3 this is ok as well like now
captured recaptured and now we've got a
critical position of the game maybe the
critical position of the game wide of
course just threaten cm but black has
got to play against deform what should
black play now in fact our own Ian here
would be enough time on the clock just
miscalculated terribly he took on deform
and allowed this capture on e6 we should
be six governed
that took it off what is black supposed
to do now it's not comfortable got there
you've only simply miscalculated he
played Bishop f7 and he obviously
believed that white now must take rook
takes and then after possible later rook
to d7 for example it's not clear this
position white it's got a protected
passport but blacks got the default so
it's sort of imbalanced
however after Bishop f7 there was a
simple move captures on f5 because the
intended move which he played Bishop c4
fails to e6 and this now it's very
critical there's simply the c7 threat
and gap blacks got nothing to show for
this he can only prevent the e pawn from
queening immediately he did so with
Queen d6 rookie one protecting rook e8
blocking the pond but white simply now
has this extremely strong porn on his
seven and I was black going to defend
against this I think there there's
nothing in fact if you look at the rest
of the game there was some position this
is actually nice tending Queen h6 that
cannot take the bishop I do this is
quite strong yeah it's really a terrible
position for black victim governed one
another pawn here Queen g5 was more
stronger so tried to attack the king
maybe look g3 then there's Queen h4 and
I mean look at this widest two pawns up
at the moment he's got an attack and
yeah it's just resign double actually
get font I should play Queen e5 he
didn't have much time on the clock you
see that
both sides they only had been oh one
minute I'm not sure that Gavin's clock
is correct he wasn't that dealer one
time not quite sure but okay he got rid
of the Queens and after this yeah I
wrote at least got upon yeah
but still it's a great porn on his 7 and
there are two passed pawns on the Kings
side while blacks pawns he's got three
against one but three against one in
this kind of situation means you don't
have an have a passport and he simply
never got got got the time to to
actually produce a passed pawn and began
some counter play um Gavin to mop this
up now protected this and now you
threatened like this and at the end
there's some check made with the rooks
enter the pawn and that it went on for a
couple of moves but there was basically
not much happening just a good technical
display careful now gave up on this e7
horn but at the end he has two passports
that are just far more advanced then
then blacks pawns here and a couple of
moves later he after King move let's say
here this rook h5 and then the H pawn
will promote yeah very nice win for for
Gaffin who took the chance when when
aronia played this inaccurate setup this
tactical sequence here Bishop c4 that
was not working because of the ebon
Galvan nicely took advantage of this and
now he's at 50% he won two games in a
row and yeah maybe he's on a roll and
the next game is against Carson with
black Jeff on wins this game I'm not
he's on plus 1000 on +2 you never know
maybe this or in his old age he hits
getting on roll and winning the rest of
his games would be
it would be quite quite funny all right
so Goodwin former girlfriend and very
very bad result for Aronian who sport
most of much of his chances now to win
the tournament it's just ok it's not
like impossible now but he needs to win
some game again
Carson really looks like he never he's
never going to lose no matter how bad
the position is and this means Aronian
must get in some win yeah an interesting
game nevertheless okay now I have a look
at a von Schaack against a job of this
game was in fact awfully long and I'm
going to do it rather quickly because
the last game requires a little bit more
attention so we've got them Queens
gambit declined and instead of Bishop f4
he want to plays Bishop g5 the classical
move and Rajah with h6 Bishop h4 and
here M he surprised with ninety form I
mean this is the last guy variation but
Laska variation usually goes like this
wave got canceled he played it simply
one move volume and this seemed like a
little bit of an imprecise way because
after Queen b3 they attack on d5 usually
you get this position with castles plate
and III plate and in this position black
can go rook FA to d8 so it's like just
put it on the board it makes no sense
because in saying but in the comparable
position that swooped the edge to cover
the pawn in the in the game you have no
roof d8 so he needed to place e6 to
cover the pond and this is a bit bit
more passive with rook e8 you actually
still have the idea to play C 75 or some
other moves and this is really a passive
line now let's just put on a couple of
moves
we get this pawn structure and in fact
this pawn structure now will stay on the
board form like 2025 moves it's a very
one-sided kind of structure where blacks
only chance is some counter play and
real play is to attack White's King with
pieces like Knight here rook e8 d 6g 6
it's yeah it's it's it's simply
difficult to do but this was we would be
black's idea and he's not really in a
position to do that and y term just
wants to increase the pressure on the
Queen side and it happens in the game
that this exchange and so why does
piling up pressure on those pawns Black
has got a nicely placed night covering
the the structure but black of course is
out of any kind of play very important
moment Queens I exchanged and this is
necessary white cannot really make any
progress with Queens on the problem is
let's exchange this that the next kind
of step is after you got this advantage
on the Queen side but advantage is nice
but how do you actually win a pawn here
it's very difficult the only way is to
really combine threats and gain space in
the center and on the Kings side and you
cannot do that with Queens on you need
to exchange the Queens as the vanship
did to actually get something in the
center and on the Kings side let's see
the following moves
yeah nights were exchanged and now the
next step is simply to expand in the
center look this is very nice now White
has got a very healthy pawn structure
and only one pawn is really your
weaknesses the d4 pawn slightly weak but
it's not that important because black
only can attack it twice and you can
easily defend it yeah the only question
is how does this might actually make
progress and the one shock effect does a
nice job in making progress here it's
playing for the e5 break and here we go
he's trying to break up like poor
information and at the end he's
intending to play with passed pawns
again those backward pawns that are far
away from even advancing and here with
the sequence white um gets into a rook
endgame which is probably just winning
there's no real defense for black he
continued for for a little while
but it's it's too much
three passed pawns it's too much and
those pawns are just are just rolling
right here black has no move after rook
takes they simply loop the edge check
Quincy seven and f7 and white gets a new
queen so very nice technical display by
even shocked I didn't get into this game
so deeply because it it really was very
one-sided where white
somehow
always had had something some advantage
and hehe nicely did this in the endgame
at the end to to win the game but it's
difficult to to do a detailed analysis
IAM of of each move it's certainly
likely that you will find some defensive
resources for black but it's very very
uncomfortable to play this position and
i think even with with good defense and
tenacious defend on the black side it's
it's it's not not nice to plain you
below them loose okay so the final game
to look at is some sweet allah against
Greece shock and this is a wild one okay
we got a King's Indians a mesh that was
too weak to expect us we'll have played
this one before already in the
tournament against against against
against our job of and won a nice game
they are ever they played this not this
line played this move attacking c4 and
we shook now place the the older move
Knight e5 and the somewhat more I know a
lot logical may centralizing instead of
putting it on the on the rim okay see
for saying so now g3 and now sweet love
and h5 immediately attacking this night
and trying to disturb white some
development the problem is this night
when it is attacked where it is supposed
to go can I go back to e2 and let's see
for hang so Bishop e2 h4 night f1 is a
rather logical way to continue as white
you don't really have a big alternative
and this is somewhat hampered now your
development black has more than one move
now but it's only one move that is
really am yeah
in the real spirit of the position and
this is what he played he played ecigs
why am in the spirit of the position
because of the most active and
principled move the thing is if you
would suggest this movement then I ask
you okay what about f4 what is this
knight actually doing you're
hard-pressed for an answer probably
because the 97 you can just take and
then g6 faults with a terrible position
for black so what what does this mean
that some squish up just blundered
where's he going in fact there is there
are some games with this move which has
been played a couple of times it looks
like a blunder but after all this the
Queen is saying and there's d4 coming so
black will get the piece back this seems
to be a bit better for white f5 is the
main move so Grisha shock probably
needed some kind of improvement and the
amazing thing is what he played here he
took on c4 which looks really ridiculous
I mean to be honest it really looks it
looks weird that this is working as only
showing that this that were playing an
amazing game um it is it's funny white
can just take it and spin them okay he
took it what else is there you need to
get get this piece and now he played b5
who shocked
yeah what is why it's supposed to do now
it's actually very tricky if white now
would go takes on b5 for example with
the light and black simply takes on d5
and this can get ugly very quickly if
white takes on Levi with the pawn for
example there's rook e8 simply rook e8
and you really have big problems to to
untie yourself on the on the if
this is actually very bad line for white
you could also think about this but then
black here also has a simple solution
you just take him and something like
this what is the Knights supposed to do
if it returns it's just this move and
white completely explodes I mean look at
all those pieces they're so
uncoordinated and you have got the King
only one which is terrible on the open
Eva to cut it short night XP 5 that's
not really a good move he took with the
bishop this is this is good black took
on d5 and now I'm sweedler played FIFA
if you really defended excellently after
this this big surprise this piece
sacrifice
um ETA XT 5 in comparison is just
answered by rook b8 it's funny that such
a quiet move is the key but the thing is
how does white untangle it's very
difficult there's this a6 idea with
taking on b2 and white is so tied down
let's say Queen d2 just to suggest a
move Queen e7 and what is white doing
now one idea for example would be this
move to sort of sort your position and
trying to harmonize it to retreat it
from this exposed square here black and
play for instance h3 and now I have a
look at this line it's not forced but it
shows how quickly it all can go downhill
g3 and RC form as strong
Bishop takes 94 and white can resign as
Knight takes e4 Queen takes e4 that's
the saying this hanging and rugby -
coming in disaster like well when pig
material now end the game so it's it's a
real minefield to this position he went
five attacking this this night and that
continue takes takes and Bishop g4 so
black attacks the Queen and yeah it's
super difficult sulla took a practical
decision um and sacrificed the Queen now
it took on f6 you can try to to keep the
Queen on but it always leads to very
uncomfortable counter play simply based
on the bad King position like central
pawns and better mobility I think this
is a very human move sacrifice the Queen
because you can see that you get lots of
pieces for it and you have chances to
coordinate your position nicely so he
took the Queen no choice takes on g7
like we captured and now Bishop takes e5
this is also important this is much
better than taking on d1 after which d4
is actually good for black blacks got
Queen against four pieces but he will
win one piece back and he's much better
coordinated Bishop c5 is stronger
because because the bishop can play a
really good role on D form blocking the
pawn and keeping your pieces active it
helps to coordinate wide if black would
play let's say Bishop h5 now white could
give this check and play along this last
93 and now white actually is able to
castle shortly with the good position
this means black needs to do something
else in this position he cannot allow
this so he played the strongest h3 this
is
strong the ideas to free the f3 scram if
white takes Nala dance Bishop f3 and
black is actually winning
it's got Queen here for example and this
is very annoying so after a three Black
is threatening this and white cannot
really take so what happens yeah well it
took on d1 and returned the material in
this way so what is this now three
pieces against the Queen
actually we thought in the analysis room
that white would have a substantial
advantage but it didn't really
materialize simply because black still
has got activity going look Tafoya may
be here Bishop deformers better but this
rook move was interesting the idea was
to get this set up with the idea of
Bishop deform and in fact with great
play but the fun thing is that black he
has a strong move and Richard found it
play d4 this is much stronger than any
other move he just the text the bishop
and wide is forced to take it with a
check and now exchange sacrifice this is
strong
Andrew p8 yeah why sacrifice the
exchange
yes simply because the the pawn on the
pond the bishop on d4 was such a strong
piece and it was better than the rook
and it's also very concrete way to play
now rook b8 takes b5 and there's also
pressure on b2 it's not so easy now for
y to react he played a 4-2 to protect it
on b5 and now a six this is really good
play really good play by by both sides I
mean this is so insanely complicated
this stuff that we should prepare here
that it's great that Sweden actually has
survived all this and got to him
position where he is actually the player
was maybe having some winning chances
however in this position he made a
mistake he took a six very quickly even
and this could have led to big trouble
for white
if [ __ ] would have seen the move Queen
e5 this attacks the rook and gets in
this Red Queen f6 check and this is
actually a rather annoying you cannot
stop this from from getting lost
White is probably playing some look
moves let's say here and something like
this and well White has always chances
to survive such a position now sometimes
those fortress types of setups it's
clear that black is the one trying to
win the end I think in fact after the
the way the game progressed with a
little time it's very difficult for y2
to manage but Grichuk didn't see that he
had planned beforehand a couple of moves
before to give this check which is not
stupid at all and this is what he
prepared otherwise it didn't make much
sense so this is actually losing meaning
that white only has this move and now
black can give this check King e2 and
rock b2 this was what we shall had
intended and it's understandable that he
may be with little time didn't double
and triple-check anything and just went
for the continuation that he had planned
all along and now blacks got quite some
counter play going with the Queen and
rook putting pressure on the King and I
think um Villa kept it all nicely
together
until we reached reached this position
where black managed to here to set this
F pawn in motion in fact the whole
seems to be rather rather draw not draw
in a way like it's a boring position
it's a very technical and complicated
position but the f-pawn simply seems to
be so strong that wife needs to return
some material and at the end he cannot
win in fact after King C 2 and F 3
Bishop did did a very clever thing he
offered the draw and this will actually
accepted it it's probably not wrong
really - to take the draw but this was
pointed out in the analysis room white
can try to play on him with various
moves a super one it's loop here and
this leads to a typical endgame Queen g2
check King somewhere no I don't know mm
or you can actually this one sorry am i
screwed this up here and now white
cannot stop this from happening so look
at four and this position this position
where you can look at a five for white
and you can easily make out that white
is never going to lose this position you
can simply stay with your rook or here
if you want
it's just nothing happening black ass
not even a check but you can argue that
white is not going to lose he's got the
a pawn and this is his effect him
probably it is still a draw with some
kind of perpetual by the Queen but
Swilly could have continued to this
position and and tried because well you
cannot lose you might as well try but I
think he was maybe - yeah - surprised by
the DF pawn that it what got so
dangerous
that he preferred to to wrap the game up
and not continue so very chaotic game
I could easily I think make a much
longer video on this game but I have my
my limits yeah so I hope you enjoyed
this I think it was a very enjoyable
round there's a rest day tomorrow on the
26th of March but of course it will
continue on on Wednesday with still I
think five rounds to go so there's much
to play form and I think already we can
say that it's a great event with very
little uninteresting games and they
fight really hard so I'm looking forward
to the new games played on Wednesday
yeah thanks for watching and I'll be
back soon
from home even with better audio so yeah
Shearson bye